pourquoi on a choisi trappe parce que on
avait le souci on a toujours le souci
dans mon livre de raconter un peu
l'époque la maison de l'étudiant a fait
le plein plus de 110 personnes ont fait
le déplacement
face à eux les deux grands reporters du
monde auteur de l'ouvragé la communauté
tout est vrai tout ce qu'on raconte est
vrai on a essayé de raconter cette
histoire sur pratiquement 50 50 années
de façon agréable aussi il faut que ce
soit un ouvrage plaisant à lire mais
rien est romancé rien inventé houle a
reçu beaucoup de courriers beaucoup de
coups de téléphone beaucoup de messages
donc ça c'est toujours très agréable
quand on écrit un livre c'est mieux que
un lieu qui tombe dans le silence ou
l'oubli et et c'est pour ça qu'on est
très content continue cette discussion
une discussion animée d'une heure et
demie dans le public des participants à
l'ouvragé d'autres qui s'estiment
oubliés des avis divergents
j'aime beaucoup les livres ces écrivains
et puis là voilà je viens de lire suis
là et j'avais vraiment envie d'entendre
leur façon de travailler sur l'effort
intéressante puisque ce qui est vécu 4 a
été vécue vécue par plusieurs communes
des yvelines et du de france je suis
trappistes depuis plus de 5 ans peut
plus de 50 ans maintenant je connais
bien train et se livre tel que m
mais ce qu'analysent c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire compte tenu de déjà
priori qu'il donne face au succès de
cette soirée la librairie du pavé du
canal envisage une autre rencontre
la communauté est paru le 3 janvier